now we've been talking a lot about the
new strain of covid on the programme
today matt hunk told us earlier that dr
susan hopkins
of public health england is probably the
leading expert in the country on this
new strain so it's very convenient that
we can now speak to her to find out more
thank you so much for being on the
program
this morning so when was this new strain
first discovered and what alerted you to
it
so new variants are found all of the
time and in particular in this strain
this was
identified initially from a patient in
september
but the whole genome sequencing was
returned in
october even then there was nothing to
particularly highlight that this was
something a major concern as variants
come and go
in late november we were trying to
understand why
kent and medway were not uh reducing
with the national restrictions
and performed details clinical
behavioral and epidemiological
investigations including whole genome
sequencing
and found that there was a cluster that
was rapidly spreading
across kent and medway that was this
variant
which we then called a variant of
interest and we tried to understand
where else it had spread
and could see it was also spreading into
london and
also essex we notified the government
last friday week
and did further work with academic
partners looking at modeling and
understanding the virus
compared to other variants that are
circulating of which there are many
uh and found that the this week that
they it all
with all the evidence stacking up that
this variant
was much more transmissible than the
other variants in circulation
uh and that made us hugely concerned and
notified government on friday
um you notified the government on friday
but surely the prime minister must have
known before that you must have been
keeping the government informed
so absolutely we were talking to the
government on a daily basis the results
of the
modeling on transmissibility
came to uh were all summarized and
presented on friday morning to the new
and emerging respiratory virus threats
advisory group
by a number of different groups around
the country doing modeling
and phylogenetic evidence of the virus
so
that was the first time that all of the
evidence came together
where the nerve tag group felt that they
could confidently say with
moderate confidence that this had higher
transmissibility than the other viruses
that were circulating i know of course
you're you know a scientist
not a politician but just listening to
the timeline the fact that you're you
know keeping
everyone informed on a daily basis why
was the prime minister still insisting
would be inhuman to cancel christmas on
wednesday
uh we did not have the modeling evidence
to show that the transmissibility
was increased or that the ore value is
increased on wednesday
okay so you're saying that about you
knew that it was spreading to london to
south east
and the east of england is there any
evidence that this variant has spread to
other parts of the country as well
so yes we have evidence that there's
there's
virus in other parts of the country but
in very small amounts
we've got two methods that we're able to
detect this so first of all whole genome
sequencing
whole genome sequencing takes two to
three weeks to return results so that we
can analyze them because it's a highly
complicated process
we know that from the whole genome
sequencing there is small amounts
in other parts but about one in 20 of
the confirmed
laboratory confirmed cases have whole
genome sequencing so when we detect it
we know there's definitely some there
uh unlikely to have some spread we then
look
at the data from the office of national
statistics coronavirus infection survey
where we monitor uh the types of genes
that are detected
and in this case this variant is not
detected by one of the
laboratory tests using the s gene and so
we're able to monitor that across the
whole country
and what we can see is that the amount
of the s gene that we can't detect has
remained stable in the rest of the
country
but has increased very dramatically in
from middle november in kent and midway
and from the
end of november beginning of december in
london and east of england
we're not seeing that anywhere else in
the country and part of the reasons that
we were
increasingly confident that it was more
transmissible is that areas that were
seeing
rapidly rising transmission were also
areas where
this variant was becoming the dominant
virus
and that's where we start putting all of
the evidence together
to confirm this we'll need laboratory
studies and those will take some weeks
um reassuring to hear that it's only
really increasing as you say
in these specific parts of the country
but where else have you
detected it so as i said it's been
detected
in many other parts of the country every
region
has cases but with very small numbers
it's also been detected in wales
in scotland we've not yet detected in
northern ireland but whole genome
sequencing has not been performed on
very many specimens
in other parts of the world the similar
strain has been in detection in denmark
australia and there are other variants
that look very similar to this
that have been detected in south africa
in the netherlands and other countries
we're not yet confirmed that those these
are the exact same as this variant
because this variant has a very clear
genetic makeup that we can follow
okay and the prime minister said
yesterday that this new variant is
believed to be
up to 70 more transmissible how
confident are you in that 70
number so um we have done
uh work with our modeling experts at
imperial to compare this variant to the
other variants that are circulating
and look and uh how we think this is
transmitting
and causing increased numbers of cases
uh the
figure of 70 is is it looks like a good
one
but we don't have very good um
confidence intervals around that so the
confidence intervals are very wide at
the moment
we're doing further work looking at the
difference with the sort of esteem
dropout which we discovered last weekend
was a marker for this variant and that
will give us an
increased amount of cases that we can
track and follow and give us better
estimates over the coming weeks so we
hope
to refine those estimates though i think
70
looks like a good number to land on at
the moment
as we refine those we will of course
tell you and the public
okay thank you for that and really good
to know a bit more detail about that
figure
um we spoke to you debbie schroeder just
before the interview with you
who was saying that it's really too
early to know whether or not the
new virus could cause increased
mortality or whether it may react to the
vaccine
in a different way is that right is it
too early to know
so of course we don't have the
laboratory experiments for the vaccine
yet
um but the vaccine should induce a broad
immune response
um and therefore this uh the mutations
that we
see on uh the spike protein in this
particular variant
don't suggest that that vaccine will not
respond yet and that of course is done
with
hypothetical studies with protein
experts who who reconstruct
what this part of the virus looks like
with these mutations
what we are clear about is that we have
further laboratory work to do we're
growing the virus at the moment in
collindale and portland and imperial and
with the
virus grown we'll be able to look at the
uh how
the virus is killed by both people
who've had the infection before
um and also people who've had the
vaccine and those will give us to finish
the answers
but those are lengthy studies that will
take a couple of more weeks before we're
able to definitively say the response
and how about the increase to the
potential of increased
mortality and we were told yesterday
there's no evidence to suggest that
people are more likely to get sick or
more likely to die if they get this
particular variant
but of course we know there's a lag
between people catching the virus and
getting ill going to hospital and sadly
dying so is it too early to know that
so i think we've got no signals um so
the first signals we would expect to see
is in the southeast where this
has definitely increased over four weeks
now so we're seeing the increases there
i think it is too early to say in london
because those increases have only
happened in the last couple of weeks
but what we know is that the more cases
that we have in the community of this
virus the more cases we're seeing in
hospital
but we're not seeing a disproportionate
number of people being admitted to
hospital
over the last two weeks um and we're not
seeing any increases
in mortality yet we do have further
studies underway where we're studying
this variant versus other variants and
trying to link that with hospital
data so we get better estimates and
we're also looking
at further studies to try and understand
that in the laboratory
but again these things will continue to
emerge over the coming weeks
um really interesting thank you so much
for talking us through all the research
you're doing it's certainly what you
know i and lots of our viewers are
fascinated by and really interested in
this morning so thank you